hey folks welcome to metaphysical
milkshake I am your co-host Reza Aslan
and I am your main host rain Wilson nice
to see you thanks for tuning in yes yes
thank you thank you for letting me be
the robin to your Batman by the way all
these years
I know you've got tights on down there I
got like really really tiny tiny around
my my ball sack area how's everything
going right now I feel like I haven't
seen you in a while but what's going on
what's what are you what are you working
well you know I've been traveling around
the world with this happiness show has
it made you any happier
no it hasn't it sucks well not yet I've
been to four countries already exploring
happiness and I've learned a ton and it
has not affected my daily life
oh dear word I understand that welcome
to metaphysical Milkshake the show where
we go deep we get weird and we search
for the meaning of Life along the way
presented by cast media and soul pancake
[Music]
it's uh so frustrating but I'm also my
head has just been in this book
oh Soul boom which comes out in April so
just uh really
hankering down on that and my head isn't
that and I haven't had much uh much
space for anything else
um you finished your book you finished
your book so I'm so down to the
Baskervilles if that's because that's
right no it is not no it is it is what's
it called again uh it's called an
American martyr in Persia and it's about
a kid named Howard basketball but it has
nothing to do with the Hound although
who knows maybe he had a dog I don't
know we're in different places you're
still finishing it up and I'm like
getting ready for the you know this book
tour and getting ready to go out into
the world you know I'm in Cell mode and
you're still in create mode I think
that's the difference yeah you know I'm
in create and finish within the next six
weeks mode
um or else or else yeah so uh but yeah
that's you gotta you gotta sell some
books man I gotta sell some sociology
history examination of Iranian turn of
the century Shenanigans no it is a it is
thrilling it is a thrilling
action-packed book about a young man who
is transformed by his experience of the
world and and transforms a country
doesn't he transform yeah it gives us
life it gives us life to a cause this is
not never gonna sell you need to you
need a viral moment you remember that
big moment you had around your Jesus
book where you were on Fox News and
they're like oh why would you a Muslim
write about Jesus oh my God how can I
get that you'll be mad at me
um uh you dug in just so expertly with
calm just dissected their argument and
it went totally viral hundreds of
millions of views you need to go on Fox
and get another viral moment well listen
I gotta it's not I'm not I'm not saying
no yeah yes I would I will gladly in
fact if there are any producers from Fox
News uh listening in uh in this podcast
uh I am totally available to come on
your network and lambast any one of your
anchors just pick one maybe Steve Ducey
he EMS like the biggest idiot of them
all but but any any one of them will do
but I will say look it's a double-edged
sword my friend going viral in that way
because obviously there's a lot of
benefits to it people hear about your
ideas and your thoughts and it starts
all these conversations but but very
quickly what happens is that it takes on
this life of its own and it becomes you
know very quickly no longer about you
and about sort of what you know you did
or what you said means about the world
and then everyone just kind of takes it
in their own Direction and as as
positive it was for me the the sort of
handful of times that I've gone viral
for one reason or another there's a lot
that goes wrong there's a lot of hatred
and anger and and threats which is why I
didn't want you to tell everybody where
I lived but thanks for that and you know
it's it just it's a reminder that
that good ideas
and bad ideas yeah spread with the same
sort of viral Force if anything I would
say bad ideas spread even more
forcefully than than good ideas do so so
the question becomes how do you how do
you spread a good idea like how how if
you have an A a movement something
that's important to you something that
that really because I was going to say
even more than a than an idea how do you
spread uh actions that are behind that
idea how do you how do you spread a
social movement how do you take that
good idea and transform it into
something that that moves the needle
forward well I've got a possible idea
about how to learn to do that how about
from uh our friend ruha Benjamin
is a professor at Princeton la di da
fancy
a masters and a PhD in sociology from
Cal Berkeley born in India I love her
stories of her background that are in
this book born in India but then grew up
in South Central LA part black part
Persian Indian hello and and has uh you
know teaches on a whole host of topics
uh about racism structural racism uh
about sort of black bodies uh social
Anatomy you know things like that [ __ ]
her last book was on was was fascinating
it was on um race and technology and
kind of the racism that's inherent in uh
technological problems yeah won a ton of
awards uh and it's just an all-around
incredible thinker and speaker but she's
got this new book out called viral
Justice how we grow the world that we
want that we're going to talk a lot
about but but you know one of the
reasons that we wanted to have her on
this show was
you know you and I have talked about
this before the world's on fire it's
really hard to kind of look around and
realize so much is going wrong and and
you want to do something about it the
question is how how can we as
individuals do something about it how do
you build a movement
Benjamin welcome to the show thanks for
having me you know I've been trying to
get you on the milkshake for two years
at least three years something like that
I know but I'm vegan so you know I was
like this milkshake yeah physical I
don't know you can use oat milk we're
fine with oat milk totally fine
I'm not really vegan just so you know
okay so excited to talk to you about
this masterpiece viral Justice what a
beautiful book too I love the cover like
it's such a pretty cover yeah what who
what's the story of this artwork again I
think you told me or I read something
about what's the story yeah so the
artist he was commissioned by the Press
by Princeton University press and so it
went through different iterations but we
really just wanted to
um Inspire this idea of growth and of
individuals taking part in seeding a new
world and so we love that it's so pretty
ready people don't realize that like
authors have almost no says exactly
exactly you're just like
luck you know well
shine elements I was looking through
your book this morning and preparation
and
because both Reza and I have book Reza's
got a book coming out in October I've
got one coming out in April all these
design decisions you've please just tell
us about the Siamese crocodiles
people that I use
a kind of course throughout the Book of
these Siamese crocodiles that share a
stomach and yet fight over food and so
it's it's you know it grows out of this
West African proverb that is speaking to
both our interconnectedness as humans
and as kind of life on the planet even
Beyond humans but also our foolishness
that we continue to fight we have the
scarcity mindset and yet we're
interconnected we share a stomach and so
it's just kind of like that refrain
throughout the book that um that speaks
to me I love that your your your vision
your mission with this story is can be
boiled down even in the asterisks that
you use in between chapters and headings
it's uh it's just fantastic but I spoke
about you a little bit before we got
started what an incredible and dynamic
powerful speaker you are the way you
make kind of social justice activism
funny accessible and also just a
continuous gut punch but what brought
brought you to this book what led to the
writing of it and I you know I read a
little bit about how connected this book
is to covid to the political unrest of
the last couple of years to kind of a
lot of the race movements that happened
post George Floyd and and many other
victims of uh racism during this time
but why this book now and what led you
to it
yeah it is a book of the moment it's we
could call it a pandemic book it really
comes down to trying to write something
that I needed at the time at the time
and so you know in some ways it was like
my form of therapy in terms of digesting
and processing all of the headlines and
all of the currents and crises that we
were all experiencing over the last few
years and yet it has this kind of longer
genealogy too because I'm really drawing
on a light of a lot of Life Experiences
things with my family that I've never
really thought like deeply about and
processed and connected to my work and
so it was this opportunity to kind of
speak to the moment but also zoom out
and think about what all of these
experiences how they're connected and
how they connect to a larger story not
just my story but our story as a
humanity and so you know the original
title was viral racism because I was
thinking about the pandemic and policing
and I remembered what a mentor of mine
once said said was that we spend so much
time naming and conceptualizing what's
ailing us the things that we don't want
and we don't carve out enough
intellectual space naming and talking
about the world we do want and so that
sort of echoed in my head and was part
of my shift from not only the title
viral racism to viral justice but also
giving enough space in the text for all
of the examples of people building a
world in the small print in nitty-gritty
ways that often don't get the attention
so in a lot of ways this is also a love
letter to people who've been doing the
work the kind of invisible labor that
doesn't often get a big headline or
hashtag or fancy award or Grant or what
have you I have so much so many uh
positive things to say about the book I
could go on and on I don't want to do
that right now but I want to say that I
I really responded to that shift that
you made you know the world that we do
want you know it's it's interesting as
um I want to talk a little bit more
about my privilege later on but in
reading some you know books over the
last couple of years around race and
racism it's always like oh you think you
understand racism wait a second you have
no idea there's this whole other other
layer of the onion you hadn't even
thought about and you have done that in
the past in some of your writings about
race and technology and you know some
really mind-blowing uh ideas that would
never come to my mind so this whole idea
that you're focusing on
almost micro Solutions is just fantastic
in the introduction
we're both members of the Baha'i faith
and in the introduction you talk about
the founder of the by faith
baha'u'llah's vision of justice and
baha'u'llah says of course the best
beloved of all things is Justice turned
not a way there from of thou desirest me
or thou desirest God how did this
spiritual vision of Justice influence
the roots of this work
in in a lot of ways it
um it balanced out my training so this
focus in that quotation that's in the
book that you just um excerpted there is
inviting us to look inward to think
about what Justice Means for us
internally a kind of reflective practice
seeing with our own eyes and not Through
The Eyes of others knowing with our own
knowledge and not the knowledge of our
neighbors so it's encouraging a kind of
internal exploration that balances out I
won't say a contrast but balances out my
training as a sociologist which is
trying to focus on these larger
processes that are often invisible that
shape people's lives so we have all of
this language right structural racism
institutional inequity
um you know huge processes that are
important to shine a light on because
many people only think about things at
an individual level but as I explained
in the book I kind of went to the Other
Extreme that kind of indoctrination of
my training and discounted the role of
individuals discounted the role that we
each play in terms of individual
volition in terms of social change and
so these two things are really
complementary because at the end of the
day you know people make up institutions
you know human and beings make up
societies we create cultures you know
these aren't things that operate outside
of us and so I think in many ways our
language can be limiting like even when
we talk about is it macro or micro like
that's a kind of false choice I think we
have to develop a new vocabulary that it
recognizes the idea of our
interdependence not even just other
human beings but ecological
interdependence like human beings right
now in relation to the planet and so I
would say you know the the choice that
we are often presented you either
look at laws and policies or you look at
individual action and volition that's a
kind of false Choice
um we have to do both and
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
uh folks
I may look like an outrageously handsome
and wildly successful podcast host all
true an actor and writer but I still got
problems no you know
I got 99 problems and a podcast ain't
one of them you know what I mean so
I use therapy to help me through my
problems on a weekly and on a monthly
basis it helps me focus on the right
things and stay out of behavior patterns
that can be well negative destructive
and set me back
so
it can be really hard to train your
brain to stay in problem solving mode
when faced with a challenge but you
learn how to find your own Solutions and
then when you do that there really is no
better feeling and a therapist
my therapist is he helps me learn how to
be a better Problem Solver and helps me
learn how to accomplish my goals no
matter how big or how small so better
help online therapy
it's got so many options you can do
video therapy you can do phone therapy
you can just even do chat therapies you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's way more
affordable than in-person therapy you
can be matched with a therapist in under
48 Hours our listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com milkshake
that's better h-e-l-p.com milkshake and
listen folks you got to take care of
yourself do you I mean you can't just
keep pretending that you can handle it
all on your own you need help just admit
it call betterhelp
you said that the book was originally
titled viral racism and now of course
it's called viral justice but this word
this this idea of a thing that's viral
is a word that you reference a lot in
the book you talk about kind of things
that we can learn from viruses in the
spread of viruses what is what does the
word actually mean to you and how is it
applied when it comes to something like
justice
to me I'm I'm using virus virality as a
lens to train our attention to the
microscopic to things that are often
um seemingly small and when we do that
and we think specifically about the
coronavirus we realize oh this thing
that we can't see that is small can
bring the planet to its knees can turn
things upside down and so if something
microscopic can do that in the negative
sense how can we think about
life-affirming processes things that are
sustaining things we want more of not
just the things we're trying to
eradicate and so it's a kind of lens to
train our attention to respect to to
create more of those things that again
seemingly small but powerful actions
habits dispositions ways of thinking and
being in the world that can have
exponential effects in ways that can be
positive ways that we can actually
engender life not not eradicate it I
don't know why but it's easier for me to
think about how something negative can
spread like a virus because fear
xenophobia you know these are bigotry
these are
almost evolutionary impulses and so they
can be turned on very easily and so and
they can spread very easily I mean all
you have to do is watch any any episode
of The Twilight Zone and and you see you
see what I'm talking about uh there's
always that one you know moment in which
like fear starts to spread like a virus
or or whatever
but what needs to happen for something
positive to spread in that same way you
know because I just it just feels so
much more difficult right to get people
to have a virality when it comes to
something good and positive and
meaningful something that affects good
meaningful change
absolutely and I think you know where I
start with that think about
what what has inspired me in the past
that's why so much of the book is also
kind of Excavating those experiences
that you know
um had uh you know were generative for
me that inspired me and so when we start
to pay attention to what gets us going
what what we are paying attention to we
see that sometimes it can be very small
fleeting words that someone says a look
that you get a feeling that's engendered
in it through an interaction and so part
of it is that what looms large in our
head is often the negative the fear you
know the the things that bring us to our
knees but once we begin to kind of like
you know go over those Pathways in our
own mind and heart about what it has
been encouraging to us what has kept us
going what has made us more courageous
what has made us love what has made us
forgive like all of those things then
the more that we sort of go on those
Pathways we grow that potential and so
part of this book is an invitation for
us again to take charge of our own minds
and not be you know not have our
attention
um directed by all of the different
forms of media and experiences that that
thrive on us being fearful and hateful
Etc and so I definitely agree with you
that it things often do seem to loom
large
um that are destructive but I don't
think that's inevitable I think that we
can control our own Attention our own
minds and then that therefore like I
meant I quote my grandma in the book we
need to water what we want to grow you
know we need to actually invest in that
so this book is just chock-a-block have
you counted the number of examples that
you give in this book of viral Justice
because it's just just when you think
you've read like The 87th then the 89th
and it's 174. it's incredible the number
of examples that you give and for our
listeners can you give us some of your
favorite examples I mean there's there's
so many there's it's as from from like
Uber drivers sharing the fact that the
uh rides are getting more expensive and
they're actually getting paid the same
or less just sharing that on a Facebook
group yep you know viral Justice can
start as small as that it can certainly
start with someone just seeing a need
and beginning a non-profit or a
community activation around some
injustice that they see on on a local
scale but I'd love to hear
after writing 189 examples of viral
Justice what are what are two or three
or four of the ones that really resonate
the most with you that you think our uh
listeners would really uh get off on and
and what can we learn from them I think
that's the other thing too like what can
the rest of us learn
yeah there again there's so many
examples it's like choosing which baby I
love more
um so let's see I do I love a lot the
examples in which everyday people take
almost take the tools that are being
used against them and wield it in the
other direction you mentioned like Uber
drivers or like you know people whose
work is being governed by algorithms who
then decide you know what
um we can figure out our own coding and
programming and flip the script and look
at the way that you know
um the people who are governing our work
are mistreating us so I love those
examples of
um taking the same tools and using it to
their own ends to more liberatory ends
against oppressive structures whether
it's in the context of Amazon which
comes up a lot or in other sort of gig
economy work
um I I think you know what what really
hits home though is a lot of the
examples that are people and
organizations in my own life that don't
even know they're in the book yet that
are going to find out in a month and a
half
you know and I think part of you know
this being a love letter is to say that
all of these ways that people have
touched me and made a way for my family
and involved me in community that I
never perhaps
um publicly acknowledge like this is
also my love letter for those
individuals in those groups and so I
kind of have a special a special place
for that I guess the last sort of
category of example though
our our movements and collectives that
are completely changing the terms of
Engagement in terms of what they're
seeking in the world and so in the
chapter called hunted which has to do
with police violence and was the hardest
to write in terms of my own you know
personal
um my family's experience with policing
and incarceration
um where there are organizations that
are saying we're not just trying to make
this system less harmful we're not
trying to just reduce the number of
people beaten or caged and make things a
little more tolerable they're completely
questioning why does this thing exist
and what can we create other than this
and so those efforts to essentially pull
the rug out and say we refuse the choice
between
um harmful and most harmful you know
what I mean and say forget that we're
gonna put on the table a third choice a
fourth choice a fifth alternative and
not just dream about it not just kind of
like write Twitter posts about it we're
actually going to start creating the
relationships in our own backyard that
have to do with engendering true safety
true well-being and how we treat one
another we're not waiting for this Pie
in the Sky to float down we're going to
start living the world that we want in
the future right now and so I feel like
that category of examples that run
throughout the book
um really get my blood going there for
me the most
um galvanizing because they question
everything but don't stay at the level
of questioning they begin to actually
work in the dirt to try to create that
world that's great and we want to get
into that more and how people do that
and how listeners can do that and how
this viral justice book can virally
spawn a viral Justice movement because I
agree with you like one of the things I
just hate about social media yeah and I
try and stay off of it as much as
possible and took it off my phone is
you know you tweet an injustice and it
gets retweeted and there's protests and
screams look look there was an injustice
the other day there was police beating
up a guy who happened to be I think he
was white but they were just like yeah
counting the [ __ ] out of this guy on the
sidewalk for no reason they could have
just put handcuffs on him it was just
Preposterous which shows you know how
grotesquely violent our law enforcement
system perceives itself as something
that needs to subjugate you know the the
communities it's supposed to serve but
we placate ourselves with like oh I
retweeted this and I said look how awful
this is and then you feel done you're a
keyboard Warrior and you just feel you
feel finished when you're exactly right
there are systems in place that are
essentially corrupt and need to be
rethought from the ground up and one of
the I think unintended consequences of
um inundating ourselves with those kind
of images and sort of letting those go
viral
um is that it ignores us our tolerance
for seeing and expecting that whether we
want to or not is also increasing like
give it a few years and that video is
not going to seem as outrageous because
we will have seen 200 since sure and so
and so you know part of it is what do we
want our media you know diet to consist
of and we need for some people who are
oblivious or who are you know stubborn
stubbornly ignorant about these things
perhaps it does them some good to
witness their witness to the harms that
are are there but for many people who
are living it we don't need to see it
you know what I mean and and and so the
question is what what are we actually
working towards that can not just reduce
but transform that status quo one of the
topics you go into a lot in the book is
health care and especially birth and
birthing of black women black women
communities something resin I don't know
anything about but I'll give you a
little glimpse so I'm I'm literally the
most privileged something we're more
than happy to talk about yes I'm gonna
mansplain exactly how this works so for
me you know I'm the most privileged guy
on the planet I'm tall white middle-aged
wealthy TV celebrity I mean I check
every single box and I had just a little
just a little taste just a little soup
song a little aperitif of this when my
wife had uh had to get an emergency
C-section and instead of going down to
St Joseph's Medical Center in Santa
Monica which is a glistening Medical
Center we were whisked away at three in
the morning and she almost died and my
son almost died because she was given
just the worst possible care and on a
gurney in a hallway as she's bleeding
from her vagina and nurses are doing
like Excel spreadsheets on their
computers and literally at one point the
nurse
goes I can't find the heartbeat just
says it like that like here you take the
paddles you know where the baby is
finally you can find the heartbeat to me
to me just absurd anyways I could go on
and on but got a little bit of a taste
of a little tiniest whiff of the
injustices of the uh of the Health Care
System you um talk a lot about
your own story about being black and
pregnant while it's Spellman you talk
about so many examples of of of black
women giving birth Health Care
inequities doulas so and the support
communities that have Arisen around this
um and the systemic injustices around
the Health Care system as affects black
women and birthing can you give us the
gist of of what you're talking about
there yes I can and so first of all I I
never knew that about
um what you all had gone through and
it's
terrible and whether you you consider it
a just a small you know dimension of
this larger problem of reproductive care
for any given family it is traumatizing
and so I just want to acknowledge that
you know you kind of live with that that
trauma of
um being neglected and being discounted
and almost dying
um so for me you know what and this is
one of those places in the book where
um I was completely spared that
experience because of
um and what I you know what I attributed
to is that I was enveloped by a
completely different model of
um pregnancy and childbirth that has a
long tradition in the South that is led
by black midwives where in the state of
Georgia even today
um community-based midwives who are not
licensed nurse nurse licensed as nurses
it's outlawed it's not good within the
law to practice so my birth at home with
a black Midwife was you know under the
radar so to speak usually they don't get
harassed unless something bad happens or
not sued unless something bad happens
but it's very rare you know for for
anything you know in fact the the kind
of of risk profile
of people who are use black midwives are
our outcomes our birth outcomes are so
much better than our counterparts in
hospitals and it's not you know there's
a lot of reasons and I explain
um but the bigger take home there again
I had a wonderful experience with black
Midwife and her Apprentice um in my home
but what I really want to offer in that
chapter is this approach to childbirth I
think is a model for how we should
approach Health Care More broadly and
accompaniment in many other areas of
life you know so the kind of
accompaniment and car the art of
encouragement the art of support and
holding space for people when they're
most vulnerable I think that applies not
just in the context of childbirth it
applies in so many critical junctures in
our lives and so I want to essentially
say black midwives are our role model
for how to
um how to seed a different world and
they're doing it like one one birth at a
time and again it's not simply about
having fewer C-sections or having slight
a slightly better rate like this kind of
incremental change because even when you
isolate
um white women
um in terms of their well-being in the
U.S the outcomes are worse than a long
list of other countries not and not just
industrialized countries in countries
that have far fewer resources so if you
just treat white women as a country
their outcomes are really poor even
though we spend more than any other
country on a high-tech um you know
health care and medicine so that itself
should be a a a horn for us to wake up
and think it's not just about getting
the like if black women were having the
same outcomes as white women like having
racial Equity that would still be bad
you know what I mean so it's not simply
racial Equity but it's social
transformation
um because I don't like Queen said I
don't want to be integrated into a
burning house and I think that applies
in the context of reproductive care as
much as anything else you know whether
it is about
Healthcare reproductive care uh racism
or income equality or climate you know
it just sometimes feels like these
issues are so huge and so overwhelming
that and especially when you look at
them you know on a global stage they
just seem unfixable it's it's very hard
not to look at some of these systemic
problems and to feel discouraged and to
throw your hands up and to just be like
you know what there's nothing I can do
about it there's no there's you know
there's no changing the world uh and so
I've given up and I think the thing
that's so encouraging and inspiring
about your book and so much a part of
sort of the the larger topic that we
want to talk about today which is you
know how to start a movement is that you
really
do talk about tackling these issues in
sort of smaller ways like starting you
know with the individual and with the
community and to not get
overwhelmed by the the just the bigness
of these problems can you talk to us a
little bit about what that process
actually looks like you know and we can
talk about racism we get that income in
quality if you want
um that those are the two things that
you mostly deal with in the book but
really any problem you know how how does
an individual think to themselves okay
I'm gonna start small I'm gonna start
with myself I'm gonna start with my
community I'm going to start with my
city whatever the case may be and and
then in a viral way
make this thing you know Global enough
to actually make a difference in the
world
that might be too big of a question but
no it's a good it's a like it's the
million dollar question but I feel like
as a as a you know the first things is
that for anyone listening who's really
in that in that space of it feeling
really overwhelming you know my my own
self-talk
um it involves quoting to myself the
words of the late great Jimmy Baldwin
who said I you know I can't be a
pessimist because I'm alive to be a
pessimist means that you have agreed
that human life is an academic matter
and so for me that says that there's
already a privilege in throwing our
hands up and saying oh I can't you know
there's too much because if you're in in
the trenches if these forces are
affecting your ability to feed yourself
or your family or to educate yourself or
to get life-saving treatment or to avoid
the deadly force of the police or to get
a job like these fundamental Goods that
people need to thrive then you you all
you almost don't have the luxury to be
like effort you know it's too big
because what's too big to one person
who's who has the luxury to sit back and
kind of you know take it all in is you
trying to grind day in and day out and
so that's why I think in the aftermath
of the pandemic when we saw the
proliferation of all of these Mutual Aid
groups on the one hand you know it
brought people into the process of
mutual Aid who before you know didn't
really have to rely on their neighbors
didn't really have to think about what
was lacking in their neighborhood and so
it was a moment of more people getting
in the trenches and so what does that
look like when we're not in crisis mode
you know I used this term and throughout
the book
um about plotting like we're plotting a
different world and I'm thinking about
that at different levels I'm thinking
about you know I was a drama major when
I first started college and so I didn't
know that about you yes I will geek out
we'll geek out so before to me there's
so much Synergy between drama and
sociology and sociology rips off a
theater all the time in our language and
we talk about you know
um social narratives and social roles
and the front stage and the backstage
like we're always ripping off theater
but the fact of the matter is like when
we think about these narratives these
plots like these narrative plots that
we've inherited these scripts that we
follow a first step in World building
and movement building is questioning
these inherited plots questioning these
roles we've been assigned you know in
fact tearing up the scripts
um and thinking about how do we become
protagonists in a different kind of
process right rather than simply abiding
by these scripts so you've inherited so
that's one idea of plotting right the
other that I'm thinking about is
literally like the idea of getting our
hands dirty in our own backyards plot
like figuring out what the plot is in
terms of um you know I I use a lot of
examples of gardening in the book in La
there's someone called the gangster
gardener who's taken the areas on the
sidewalks in front of their yards and
created these edible Gardens right and
so how we use that as a metaphor and I
want readers to think about what their
plot is right and really to I want us to
respect all of the different ways that
people can get involved right I the last
line of the book is that we have to
respect the loud and ferocious World
Builders as much as the quiet and
studious ones that we all have a role to
play and for me it makes perfect sense
because we got here to the this this
Crossroads of multiple crises through
many different angles top-down policies
and laws sideways cultural norms
everyday bottom-up actions like the
oppressive status quo was created
through all of these Pathways which
means all of these these pathways are
ways for people to get involved and so I
want I want listeners to think about
what gets their blood boiling what keeps
you up at night what pisses you off like
what pisses me off is such a motivator
and a fuel like you know my my hands
will be banking on the keys of the
keyboard because I'll be so angry about
something that's a good sign you know to
think about what pisses you off and then
crucially crucially
to look around and look at who is
already working on that front rather
than trying to be a lone savior or hero
or create a new app for this or a new
business venture that deals with
whatever problem you've discovered you
know get getting out of that
entrepreneurial mindset and and getting
into a collaborative posture and
thinking about how you can put your
skills and energy to the service of
organizations that have probably been
working on that front for longer than
you've been alive
um and so to me it's crucial to tap into
what you're passionate about but not to
be ruled by Passion to actually learn
from the organizations the communities
the movements around you and work in
solidarity with them I love that that's
that's so important
um and I think that's
I was talking to a friend who came from
Australia who moved here from Australia
recently and in Australia he was talking
about like
it has a lot of collectivism the
Americans have such an entrepreneurial
bent on everything like everything is
about the individual and the sanctity of
the individual and the the power of the
individual and so I guess really what
we're asking when we're talking about
you start starting a viral Justice
movement is we're talking about
the individual working in conjunction
and in cooperation and in collectivism
uh for that change and we have to kind
of set aside our American kind of like
gung-ho Cowboy way of doing things I'm
thinking about however someone I got to
know a little bit was Greta tunberg and
just that's and that's when I share you
know around this topic with young people
at college campuses I always talk about
Greta because it's so doable it's like
here's a girl on the Spectrum she read
an article about climate change she's
like why is no one wait a minute that
we're killing the Earth no one's sitting
around and just having coffee and going
about their lives and every Friday she
just made a dumb little sign and sat out
there and then eventually got
interviewed and then the interview
spread and then it really went viral and
she has hundreds of millions of
followers and you know have we fixed
climate change no but has she made a
dent has she moved the needle especially
with young people absolutely and I love
that you quote uh an activist from
um Philadelphia named Stephanie Keane
and when people ask Stephanie Keane what
should we do especially privileged folks
like what should we do to help and she
says do what you're good at can you talk
a little bit about that
absolutely and so it's this you know
this marriage of passion and skill and
you know she talks about if you like to
cook you know she says revolutionaries
need to eat if you're good at data we
need the Nerds you know if you're in the
Arts like every movement has to be
revitalized through music through song
and storytelling like that's not icing
an extra on the cake it's the heartbeat
of any movement worth its salt and so
when we begin to actually expand our
imagination of what it will take then
you it it engenders a deep respect of
what everyone brings to the table you
know like you can't do it without the
data nerds or the you know the Airy you
know like musicians or the you know like
not everyone needs to be good at the
same thing Keen says like that that's
not what makes a movement and so we have
to carve out space for us to you know
not just bring our different capacities
and skills but to really respect what
people are bringing to the table and
also to leave room for conflict and
consultation and debate you know it's
not all you know
um Kumbaya but I think what essentially
through our kind of again a media
saturation of a particular poster child
of activism a particular kind of image
of what uh you know uh uh uh Advocate
looks like or sounds like dresses like
you know what lingo they use you know
what buzzwords it Narrows the scope and
it actually becomes the veneer of
something rather than you know the the
substance of what we need to work on you
know one thing that's
kind of difficult when it comes to
building movements is you have to create
some kind of shared identity uh amongst
a diverse group of individuals right I
was thinking about this um interview
that Andrew Yang who anybody who follows
me on social media knows I am not a fan
of on the contrary I I just think he is
an unserious joke but you know he's got
this he's got this party now called the
forward party
and it's supposed to be neither right
nor left it's all of us and our ideas
are neither liberal nor conservative
they're forward
and so he did this interview that kind
of went a little bit viral in which an
anchor asked him okay but like you have
to have positions right like so for
instance what is your party's position
on abortion
and he's like you know we don't have a
left position or a right position we
have a forward position and the anchor
does not have the ability to say what
the [ __ ] are you talking about [ __ ]
like I do but it occurred to me that you
know from that interview one of the most
difficult problems with creating social
movements it's and even those you know
focused on things like justice or income
equality is that on the one hand your
strength comes from drawing people from
all over the place right the whole
political Spectrum different races
different uh you know social classes uh
etc etc on the other hand you have to
figure out a way to get everybody to
kind of accept a singular idea a
singular narrative a singular movement
you know something something that that
you can all just kind of use as a means
of identity could you talk a little bit
about how how do we create something
that is uh meaningful and uh and has the
ability to draw a large audience it is
diverse but still at the same time is
uncompromising in the the values that it
is putting forth
I think that distinction is important
that the kind of diversity of
dispositions and skills and capacities I
referred to earlier has more to do with
the how of how we do things not the what
the kind of uncompromising what what are
the principles on which any movement is
built and I think one place to start is
really thinking about what tradition are
we building on when we are working to
Foster any kind of social change or
movement we're not starting from scratch
we're not you know again it's not this
entrepreneurial mindset always trying to
be original we're thinking about what
whose shoulders do we stand on what
tradition are we building on and so if
we're talking about the long Freedom
struggle in this in this country Then
There are a set of principles around
Justice
um around Equity that are uncompromising
and there are also pragmatic ideas about
how we do that right in terms of what
kind of economic system what kind of
political system educational system do
we need and and so I think we need to
distinguish between
um really having Open Arms in terms of
how we work together and what we bring
to the table with understanding that
there's a set of of principles around
um you know the the distribution of
goods and resources and respect that
allows everyone to live a flourishing
life and not all economic systems will
get us there not all political systems
will get us there to ensure that
everyone has what they need to live a
flourishing life and so I think it's
something also that requires ongoing
sort of calibration like we don't just
decide at one point in time these are
these are the principles we stand for
this is how we get there we have to also
constantly be checking if we're adhering
to those Noble principles and those and
those ideas and so it's a kind of
ongoing
um exercise in humility and
self-reflection that has to happen at a
collective level as well
this uh book is is fantastic and um I
really thank you too for sharing your
personal story so much throughout it I
was very moved by those anecdotes and a
lot of the suffering that you've
undergone personally uh along this path
um and in a book published by Princeton
University press that's a pretty rare
thing to kind of have some personal uh
this is peer reviewed I understand
probably but to have stories of your of
your family life working life your
growing up life your struggles uh is
super important and it's an exciting
book and I just wish you the very best
in promoting it launching it and may it
launch another ten thousand uh instances
of viral Justice around the globe thank
you so much for yes thanks for joining
us thank you thank you for joining us on
the metaphysical oat milkshake
thanks Reza thanks Ray
so wow so much to think about yeah viral
movements what a speaker I want to see
her speak live she seems oh she's
Dynamic she's really hard-hitting and
dynamic and just
um all kinds of stories and examples uh
not theoretical you know really just
down down in the dirt of social really
great advice yeah great advice about how
to start movements and and uh so let me
ask you this what you know movements are
important
um we there's a lot that needs changing
in the world it can be overwhelming like
you said earlier on
um what social movement would you would
you start I mean if you had an
opportunity Reza like in your life right
now and you were able to kind of start a
little virus in your neighborhood and
you know Highland Park
neighborhood of of La uh five four five
four please don't tell people I'm sorry
sorry people who hate me already uh but
this is a fascinating question if I
could start a movement that would start
small individual and then have the the
virality to like take over the globe and
to really change things for the good I
guess uh yeah I would have a a movement
about how to use proper grammar I think
that's that's what I would that's a
that's a big Global problem you know if
you if you think about it in a global
sense it becomes uh a little too heavy
too much uh unfixable but if I start
going around annoying the people in my
community about the proper difference
between your and your or when to use
that and when to use which
then I think I I could then use that to
create a global movement dedicated to
proper grammar
does that
sound about you sound like one of those
Twitter grammar police
that's always correcting the your and
your you are and your thing what about
you what about you certainly nothing
nearly as important or okay I'm gonna go
oh I'm gonna go A Step Above uh uh of
grammar I mean that is crucial I think
good grammar is is one of the most
important
um
uh thingies topic so we could we can
focus on one of the greatest needs of
humanity moving forward but I guess for
me uh similarly I always think this when
I'm driving I'm always thinking like
if
if you if there's a big long line of
cars on the 101 merging into the 405
into LA and you don't wait in that line
and you go in the left lane and you kind
of cut around and then you duck in at
the last minute so you're cutting in
line just like you would cut in line
yeah at a movie theater if if that is
still happening how are we ever going to
affect true social change because you're
putting yourself up ahead of the
collective so I believe that social
transformation begins on the freeways it
begins on the highways it begins at the
stop signs it begins at the red lights
and at the yield signs where we all need
to drive with great compassion and we
need to drive
as if the golden rule is is is powering
our our engine also don't pass on the
[ __ ] right lane don't pass on the
right lane don't do it an entire an
entire movement dedicated to not passing
on the right lane I think that's that's
that has the potential for Global
transformation
I really do yeah uh what about you dear
listener uh do you have an idea for a
movement it could be a small movement
Global movement let us know you can find
us on social media at Reza Aslin and
Rayne Wilson and on Twitter at metamilk
podcast we're on Instagram at
metaphysical milkshake let us know what
your social movement would be and and uh
and if you have any sort of big life
questions too we'd love to hear those
actually here's something cool we are
giving away five copies of ruha's book
viral justice so it's great because
it'll give you a ton of ideas about how
to actually affect global change
um all you gotta do it's very easy you
gotta write a review for metaphysical
milkshake on Apple podcasts it doesn't
have to be a positive review but if it's
a negative review we might accidentally
lose your email but all you got to do is
is uh email a screenshot of it to
metaphysical at cast media that's cast
with the K media.com metaphysical at
castmedia.com
first five people who do it will get a
copy of the book please no PO Boxes and
please only uh us residents because we
just can't can't afford to send it to
Peru we just can't
we just can't do it we don't have the
budget you don't know you don't know how
little Money podcasts make us my friend
like uh you can also subscribe to
metaphysical milkshake on our YouTube
channel and watch us having these
scintillating conversations watch full
episodes each week we'll see you next
week thanks so much for tuning in
milkshakers we love you see you next
week metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rain Wilson Reza Aslan and
Colin Thompson it is produced by Safa
samasade Yaz Aeris Lane Mick demaria
Hashem South and DJ lubel cast media is
the production and distribution partner
original music by Jeff Tang
foreign
[Music]
I'm always thinking about that but I
don't actually write it I'm always
thinking to myself like
you mean your
it's still Rife with judgment
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
YouTube channel thank you